quarantine confession lin-manuel Miranda  last night a spider walked across my  face and I didn't brush it away it felt  nice to be touched  confession to make it look like I take  more steps every day I taped my Fitbit  to the dog  I wanna flesh once I had a sex dream  about doctor foul Chee it was noon and I  wasn't asleep  quiet fashion since quarantine began  I've had at least three full days where  I just forgot to open my eyes go on a  fashion it's always been my dream to  write a musical about beef jerky whoa  beef jerky how I longed for your time  fashion my real name is Larry Marty  Matheson Manuel Miranda Quarantine  confession